so this is a Lego Mindstorm robot which
we've hacked together into a semi
autonomous robot which should be able to
drive around the room on its own this
robot is a Lego Mindstorm with a battery
pack strapped on top and a Raspberry Pi
underneath and Raspberry Pi send signals
to the little receiver on top to control
the motors now once you have control
like that you can you can program the PI
to essentially control the robot it can
drive around on its own semi
autonomously currently I've got this
infrared controller which sends in print
signals from the remote to the receiver
on top this was initially how we
received the robot with a few bits and
bobs plugged on top including the PI
then we've just hacked together a bit of
solution so that we could automate the
control using the sensors instead we've
got a Raspberry Pi on the back which is
PI model B and we've got a breadboard on
top for only little wires on and we've
got infrared LED which sends out a
signal we pulsed this LED at a certain
oscillation which corresponds to the
signals you can receive from the
receiver on the machine so that
essentially allows us to control the
robot itself we also have some
ultrasonic sensors plugged into the
front or back left and right
obviously on each side and what we do
here is we essentially we do recall what
we do Marcopolo
and then we calculate the distance to
the objects immediately in front back
left and right they send that one signal
and it will bounce off all of the
obstacles in the room it'll send a
resultant signal back which will get
received by the receiver so in a sense
you're screwing Marco and then polo
getting the signal back and then the
robot does a bit of a naive naive search
and essentially moves in the direction
where it's not going to hit things
now this isn't perfect the robot itself
is actually quite naive so the sensors
on the front the back left on the right
they're good for about thirty degrees of
range but there are blind spots on the
corners and the front and the back by
the wheels yeah sometimes this isn't
great because you can hit very thin
obstacles which the sensors don't
necessarily get in range something such
as a pole or something so it's it's not
it's not perfect but it's good enough if
you want to send it into an environment
where you
can't necessarily go here we're just
trying it out with some different
objects in a smaller environment we
hacked together so we've got a small PC
in a bit of wood and just a small little
cage to drive around in the idea is that
they should robot should be able to
drive around on its own and not crash on
the walls most of the time again not
perfect but it's a good little
demonstration of a naive a naive search
row potentially so I'm just going to
plug it in to the monitor we can connect
to this wirelessly this robots normally
setup on a static IP but due to some
difficulties in the new network we've
got installed it's not working right now
so I'm just gonna plug it into the
monitor and do it that way instead so
it's a Raspberry Pi model B and it's got
the standard operating system on which
is a thing they call it noobs in terms
of wiring each sensor has a ground and a
five volt rail and then it's got input
and output signals so the white wire is
to send a signal to pulse the sensor and
the back wire is to receive a signal
back so essentially each one of these
sensors has four cables and those four
cables are powered and controlled by the
Raspberry Pi which is underneath the
breadboard we would have soldered this
together but we're a rapid prototyping
when we made this and we just wanted to
get something that works the Raspberry
Pi operating systems booted up now so we
should be able to access the come online
I've written a program called Roma in
C++ we should allow the robot to drive
around semi autonomously
such a hack it's taking in data from the
sensors and it's thinking about where
it's going to drive so the idea is it
should be constantly polling the sensors
in order seeing what data it can collect
from the environment so this data will
consist of distance data around it and
more specifically the measurements are
in centimeters so the the sensors
themselves have a range of about four
meters which means the robot can drive
in an area of about four meters squared
but again it's it's a naive robot so it
may not pick up things below the sensors
or may not pick up things out of the
range of the sensors but it's not got a
tilt sensor either has it no no there's
no there's no accelerometer on it it
would have been something related if we
had more
but and I think that's what's called
backing yourself into a corner yeah
nothing's perfect
so it reaches the right depth in your
brain we're taking a baseline now that
means we're asking max to relax while we
take an average of his brain activity